[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de ce
qui Mac consacré aux jeux olympiques les
Jeux Olympiques auront lieu vous le
savez du 26 juillet au 11 août 2024 mais
un peu plus d'un an auparavant c'est
déroulé ici même sur le site du Golf
National la journée olympique la journée
olympique ça permet à des jours de
découvrir des sports et même de si
essayer parce que vous savez les Jeux
olympiques sont un événement sportifs
planétaire mais c'est aussi un
événements populaires considérable et à
ce propos nous avons rencontré Ludivine
de Blast qui est chargé de projet
événementiel à la des directions des
sports de Saint-Quentin et qui nous
présente le site de célébration alors le
site de célébration il sera situé sur
l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il sera ouvert
à tous gratuit il permettra d'assister à
toutes les épreuves des JO et vous allez
voir c'est bien plus qu'une fan zone
l'objectif c'est vraiment d'avoir un
endroit où les gens vont pouvoir se
rassembler vivre l'émotion des jeux
c'est hyper important parce qu'on sait
très bien que tout le monde n'aura pas
la chance en fait d'avoir son billet ou
ses billets pour pour les épreuves
olympiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut venir en famille entre amis
entre collègues boire un verre manger
pratiquer regardez épreuves et on a à
cœur et de leur donner envie de faire du
sport
[Musique]
on veut vraiment que ce soit the place
to me parce que les Jeux Olympiques on
les aura qu'une seule fois dans notre
vie encore plus sur notre territoire
l'idée c'est aussi de pouvoir accueillir
les athlètes célébrer nos athlètes on
espère on croise les doigts pour que des
50 chinois reviennent avec avec des
médailles on a prévu des concerts aussi
en soirée deux trois soirées
exceptionnelles avec notamment les
épreuves de BMX qui se dérouleront en
nocturne
50 ans c'est quand même le deuxième pôle
économique de loi de parisienne donc on
a un certain nombre d'entreprises qui
sont partenaires officiels des Jeux
Olympiques et qui ont aussi envie pour
leurs salariés pour leurs clients de les
inviter au fur et des jeux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on aura des touristes qui sont présents
sur sur le territoire donc on a prévu
aussi de les accueillir et de leur faire
découvrir aussi le savoir-faire à la
française l'agriculteur locale nous on
compte à un moment donné pouvoir vendre
du jus de pomme local dans la Fan Zone
sous l'égide de made in Sky ça c'est la
première fois qu'on aura le droit sous
une marque institutionnelle en fait de
commercialiser des produits au sein d'un
site officiel de Paris 2024 puisque la
fameuse sera un site officiel
ça va être fabuleux ça c'est incroyable
de pouvoir bosser sur des projets des
projets comme ça
[Musique]
bonjour Laurent mazory bonjour Patrice
vous êtes vice-prés Uno de 50 ans en
charge des sports et des Jeux Olympiques
alors il y a eu cette journée olympique
à la ça y est le compte à rebours est
lancé ah oui complètement une journée
olympique qui a vu plus de 1000 élèves
des CM2 de collège et des lycées venir
et puis le lendemain quasiment toute la
population de 50 ans en Yvelines alors
on vient de voir justement le site de
célébration qui va être cet endroit où
on va être au cœur des JO et on va
pouvoir aller gratuitement assister aux
épreuves est-ce que ça fait partie d'une
volonté qui est celle de Saint-Quentin
qui la vôtre aussi de faire de ces JO
une grande fête une grande fête
populaire oui tout à fait l'objectif de
cette fan d'eau de ce dieu de
célébration c'est pouvoir accueillir un
maximum de notre population de faire de
50 ans Yvelines qui sera la capitale des
Jeux Olympiques à Paris également une
capitale pour toute notre population il
y a ceux qui ont la chance d'avoir des
billets une partie de la population ceux
qui n'en n'auront pas et donc cet espace
sera prévu pour eux mais également pour
les touristes qui en ont visité qui
entre deux épreuves pourront passer sur
cette fan zone et venir voir les autres
épreuves et ça sera également un lieu
exemplaire pour montrer le savoir-faire
des entreprises de 50 ans divine et
impliquer notre population à participer
à ce grand événement mondial que sont
les Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 le
romanzaury évidemment toute cette
organisation demande des bénévoles vous
avez déjà commencé évidemment le
recrutement oui alors nous avons eu une
première vague de recrutement pour les
bénévoles directement sur les sites et
aujourd'hui ce sont tous les bénévoles
qui vont accueillir ceux qui viendront
de visiter pour les accompagner depuis
la gare jusqu'au site pour les orienter
pour les aider dans toutes ces démarches
qu'ils auront à faire entre différentes
sites pour les accueillir y compris dans
l'île de loisirs pour notre lieu de
célébration notre Fan Zone ils vont être
en contact direct avec tous ces
touristes ou c'est pas exceptionnel de
sport qui viendront sur notre territoire
et d'ailleurs il y a un site qui est
dédié à ça qui s'appelle ski et les
jeux.fr vous pouvez aller voir il y a
tous les renseignements nécessaires et
puis on va rejoindre Maxime Lucas eu le
cas qui est en charge justement du
bénévolat et qui va tout dire sur on
peut faire encore pour devenir parce
qu'on peut encore bien sûr mais comment
se renseigner et qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire tout des renseignements et puis on
se retrouve après avec plaisir
[Musique]
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines sera l'une des
places fortes des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 puisque avec
quatre sites olympiques un site
paralympique il se passera quasiment des
choses tous les jours à 50 ans en
Yvelines on peut le voir aujourd'hui on
est sur une journée olympique qu'on
organise et pour cet événement on a
besoin déjà de 100 bénévoles sur la
période des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques on a estimé nos besoins
environ 500 personnes qu'on doit
recruter
nos bénévoles seront le premier sourire
que les spectateurs vont rencontrer en
arrivant à 50 ans en Yvelines nos
bénévoles guideront les spectateurs des
gares jusqu'au site de compétition cette
mission est super importante on veut que
les spectateurs qui viennent sur 50 ans
en Yvelines vive la meilleure expérience
possible et donc pour cela on a besoin
de les guider de les orienter les
recevoir de leur fournir toute
l'information nécessaire
[Musique]
la deuxième mission qui va être confiée
à nos bénévoles c'est l'animation et
l'encadrement de notre Fan Zone notre
site de célébration ou tous les 50
chinois et tous les gens du monde entier
vont pouvoir venir faire la fête et là
ça va être vraiment être acteur de la
fête et faire en sorte que tout le monde
vive ses jeux le plus pleinement
possible
l'idée c'est que nos bénévoles puissent
avoir une vraie plus-value de leur
expérience
de bénévole sur les jeux on proposera
des cours d'anglais pour nos bénévoles
et des cours au premier secours pour
qu'il soit le plus confiant dans les
missions qui leur seront confiés pendant
les Jeux
pour rejoindre ce programme et
participer aux missions qui seront
confiées à nos bénévoles pendant les
Jeux c'est très simple pour cela il
suffit d'avoir 18 ans révolu au premier
juillet 2024 par les Français et Anglais
toutes les langues supplémentaires
seront en plus et le dernier critère
c'est la disponibilité on veut que nos
bénévoles soient au minimum disponibles
8 demi-journées sur la période des jeux
[Musique]
alors il y a évidemment beaucoup de
façons de participer à ces JO alors il y
a les champions comme nous évidemment
les sportifs il y a les spectateurs il y
a les bénévoles dont on vient de parler
et puis aussi des entreprises qui sont
très présentes dans l'organisation et
dans la le déroulement de ces jeux oui
alors tout à fait au-delà des financeurs
puisque évidemment les entreprises
parlent les relations marketing qu'elles
entretiennent sont des financeurs c'est
surtout un des objectifs de poursuivons
à 50 ans les mines c'est ouvert le lien
entre nos spectateurs notre population
et les entreprises nous sommes ici sont
un territoire d'innovation ici sur un
territoire Bénédicte des dieux en
matière d'emploi l'emploi ce sont les
entreprises également le financement de
l'agglomération ils les entreprises sont
parties prenantes en tant qu'actrice des
jeux puisqu'elle participent directement
à sa nombre de travaux elles sont
actrices directement parce qu'elle
participe à l'animation des jeux en
rendant un salon de prestations et puis
elle participe à l'image des jeux en
portant la parole des Jeux Olympiques
qui en affichant sur son bâtiment son
engagement en matière de jeu olympique
mais également paralympiques qui d'autre
en participant au relais de la flamme et
les entreprises vont permettre à notre
population de d'avoir encore plus un
sentiment d'appartenance au territoire
en partant haut les valeurs du sport à
travers leurs propres identité et puis
nous avons sur le territoire des
entreprises je n'en citerai pas pour pas
faire publicité mais qui sont déjà des
grandes actrices du sport individuels et
collectifs et pas que pendant les Jeux
Olympiques et tout ça va encore plus
continuer se montrer pendant la période
olympique et bien moi je vais en citer
une puisqu'on est allé voir c'est la
Banque Populaire Val de France et
Elisabeth Moreau directrice générale
adjointe de cette banque populaire
explique pourquoi de son entreprise a
voulu être un des acteurs des Jeux
Olympiques
d'abord on a à cœur bien sûr de d'être
présent auprès des PME on est première
banque DPME donc on les guide dans les
appels d'offres qui peuvent les
concerner aujourd'hui on a environ une
dizaine d'entreprises qui ont déjà été
sélectionnées pour participer aux Jeux
Olympiques dans leur domaine d'activité
on a bien sûr à coeur aussi de faire
participer nos clients nos sociétaires
au travers notamment du relais de la
flamme puisque on va permettre à des
clients à des sociétaires de porter la
flamme
[Musique]
20 collaborateurs de la Banque Populaire
val-de-france ont été sélectionnés pour
être au plus près des Jeux Olympiques
donc à l'intérieur des sites dans
l'organisation de l'événement dans
l'accueil du public ils vont aussi
défier nos athlètes on accompagne très
athlètes sur notre territoire des
athlètes régionaux certains ont fait
leur classe juste à côté ici à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines je pense à
Timothée Adolphe qui est né à Versailles
qui a appris l'athlétisme à Guyancourt
qui aujourd'hui sprinter non voyant je
pense à Léonie perio qui est agrandi à
Vélizy et qui est licencié à Versailles
elle est triathlètes elle a déjà obtenu
des médailles voilà je pense à Marie le
net qui s'entraîne au Vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin qui fait partie de
l'équipe de France de cyclisme
[Musique]
on est très attaché au côté local on a
des agences disséminées sur l'ensemble
de nos territoires et notre siège social
est à Saint-Quentin en Yvelines donc
bien sûr ça a du sens pour nos clients
pour nos collaborateurs aussi qui ont
beaucoup de fierté d'être partenaires
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
avec des sites qui sont très proches de
notre siège
[Musique]
alors on a vu les différentes façons de
participer à ce jour qu'on soit encore
une fois sportive champion mais aussi
bénévole mais aussi le tissu économique
où vous êtes justement en charge des
spots des Jeux Olympiques
ça doit être très excitant notre un an
comme ça de ce grand événement c'est
juste Patrice c'est excitant c'est
prenant on y découvre beaucoup de choses
en fait c'est beaucoup d'autres choses
que le sport c'est l'aménagement c'est
de l'organisation c'est l'électricité
enfin ça a beaucoup pas voir en fait
avec l'équipement d'un territoire plus
qu'avec la partie sportive cette partie
sportive elle nous arrive de manière un
peu plus verticale mais par contre tout
ce qui est par exemple d'aménager
quelque part 30 ans en avance par
rapport à un planning normal c'est un
petit peu cela si on prend le cas de la
colline des longs courts probablement
aurions-nous mis encore 20 ans avant de
pouvoir l'équiper je pense à nos amis de
saint-auce unique le village des
athlètes qui permet également qui
permettra dans l'héritage de loger des
milliers de gens et c'est un peu ce côté
là en plus qui va au delà du sport qui
rajoute quelque chose de passionnant le
sentiment un petit peu de relancer à
nouveau notre ex ville nouvelle en ayant
des aménagements extraordinaire même si
à 50 ans la chance d'en avoir déjà
beaucoup ici le groupe national existe
le Drôme existe mais par exemple la
colline d'Élancourt n'existe pas
n'existera donc ça c'est très excitant
et puis impliqué la population et les
entreprises dans ce grand événement que
le monde entier regardera ici en France
ici à 50 en Yvelines c'est juste
passionnant et personnellement c'est
aussi peut-être un des grands moments de
votre vie oui c'est juste j'avoue que
j'attends avec impatience de voir la
concrétisation de ce travail mais c'est
un grand moment pour moi c'est un grand
moment pour toute l'équipe de 50 ans
pour les douze communes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et pour que
toute l'équipe des sports mais également
de tous les services Saint-Quentin qui
sont impliqués d'en faire de ce moment
une belle réussite et l'image de
Saint-Quentin et de la France dans le
monde et bien merci beaucoup
le 26 juillet 2024 ça va arriver très
vite finalement très très vite merci
beaucoup merci Patrice
[Musique]